so that was the first question you can
get a sense of how I'm using the
technology really to deal with the
integrals but I still have to do a lot
of thinking myself let's have a god the
next one out of a sample of 30 rats so
that's obviously an important number
right there estimate the number expected
to complete the maze in a time between
45 and 55 seconds so those are the other
important numbers now in order to work
this out what I'm trying to find is
where am I on my curve here so 45 is
just below beneath the mean so it's
going to start around there and then I
have to go all the way up to 55 so it's
just past that first thinnest deviation
above the mean right so I already know
because I have this is an empirical
result that that one bar there between Z
equals 0 and Z equals 1 I know that's 34
percent so I'm going to expect a
percentage a little more than that
because I'm going a bit below and a bit
above as well but then what I want is
that proportion not just that as a
percentage I don't want the probability
I actually want the number out of a
sample of 30 rats so once I get my
probability I'll multiply that by 30 and
fingers crossed that will give me an
approximate number over rats let's have
a go I need just like I have in the
previous question a time this time I
have to convert to a z-score because I'm
using an integral which all has said so
let's have a go at getting 45 and 55 I'm
as dead scores so this is what I'm out
to zoom out a bit this is part two I
don't think I wrote part one when I was
working this out so I'm just writing
part one here so I have two times I've
got 45 and then I've got 55 just
double-check that those other correct
boundaries yes so I want the z-score
that corresponds to each of these so for
45 I'm gonna get 45 takeaway we said the
mean was 46 and then I divide by my
standard deviation so I can already tell
45 takeaway 46 is just the negative one
and then I divide by 8 and I'll do the
same thing for the highest score so I'm
gonna get 55 take away my mean divided
by my standard deviation 55 takeaway 46
that's 9 over 8 so unlike in the first
part that we were just looking
I'm here I have nice numerical lower
boundaries and upper boundaries and this
is what I'm going to substitute into my
probabilities so I can say that the
probability of being between 45 and 55
is going to be exactly equal to this
particular integral I go from my lower
one negative one over a which I got from
here and then I go to my upper one nine
over eight of my probability function so
1 over root 2 pi e to the negative 1/2 Z
squared DZ that's going to give me a
probability so let's go ahead and I'm
going back over to my technology lucky
for me I've already done most of the
hard work by putting in the integrand
now I just need to change the boundaries
so I'm gonna change the bottom one let's
change that it's negative 1 over 8 and
then I will also change the upper
boundary to known divided by 8 and I get
this number here so let's have a look
we'll drop this down and then we'll
start to interpret it so I've got zero
point four one nine four four dot
that'll do
so getting about 42% which you might
recall we were expecting something you
know above 34% which this is in the
right ballpark it's it's obviously going
further above and further below than
just a little smidge so 41% is a decent
chunk past 34 42% I should say so we
noted before that this was not the
answer we wanted to make a prediction
about a sample of 30 rats so therefore I
can say therefore I'm going to just make
that a bit smaller expected number
equals um 30 times this this probability
that I got 30 multiplied by this
probability so again I'm going to go to
technology to work this out in fact I'm
just going to go ahead at the front of
the integral and I'm going to put that
multiplication by 30 right there so I
get I've got a number there of twelve
point five eight three three etc no good
having 0.58 of a rat so therefore I'm
going to conclude by saying we
expect 13 I can't remember if it's rats
or mice its rats I was right we expect
13 rats
within 45 to 55 seconds so again you can
see the technology really comes in
almost at the very end just to do that
hard number crunching for me to evaluate
that integral but even once you've got
those numbers you still have to do
thinking about interpreting those
results in light of the situation that
you're dealing with all right
so part 1 part 2 done let's have a look
at this calculate times within which you
would expect 95% of the rats to complete
the maze so this question is unique
among all the rest of them in that we
actually don't really need technology to
do this because 95% is one of the nice
neat numbers that we got from the
empirical results around the normal
distribution we know that within one
standard deviation we get 68% within two
standard deviations that's when we get
95% so I just need to know what two
standard deviations below and two
standard deviations above is and that
will give me the time range so and this
is I don't need my calculator here and
this is part three so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna write this using some
notation I know so the average plus two
standard deviations will be I think we
said it was forty six plus two lots of
eights because those are the numbers
I'll just double-check them on my graph
up here yes
46 and eight so last I checked two times
eight was 16 so 46 plus 16 is going to
give me 62 seconds so that's my upper
boundary and I'll do the same thing I'm
just not a sigma mu I'll do the same
thing to work out the lower time at
boundary so that's going to be 46 take
away 2 lots of paint so 46 take away 16
this gives me 30 seconds so therefore
95% at least this is what our model
tells us 95% of rats will be within this
time range instead of 30 to 60 two
seconds okay now at this point they then
introduce a second group of rats
very sadly have been denied food for
four hours and then they get sent
through the maze as well and then we get
their times so this is kind of like
calling back you know when you have a
look at this data set this is calling
back to back room area and you know like
he is eight nine and ten where we just
got given numbers and we had to
calculate some of those measures of
central tendency and measures of spread
because that's what we're asked to do
right away calculate the mean and
standard deviation of these results now
I could do the mean just by adding and
dividing by how many scores there are
but because I can see I need to go to
the standard deviation as well I might
as well go directly to my calculator use
the statistics function to evaluate
these and so because it's been a while
since we've done this let me refresh
your memory of how we actually put these
because of data into there and I'm
calculate mean and standard deviation so
the first thing you want to do is change
the mode of your calculator you're
usually in mode one which is for
computation we're going to go over to
mode 2 for stat and then when you have a
look at this I've only got a single
variable so I'm going to go for one one
variable and so there's X which is going
to be our x so I'm going to go ahead and
go to the list of numbers and input them
so I get 4321 46:58
third one 1755 29 22 and 19 I'll just do
a quick double check to make sure that I
have entered all of those they look good
okay fantastic so all my data is now
entered I'll clear that out and now what
I'm going to do is just use the fact
that mean and standard deviation can be
handed to me directly with no more
calculation of my part so I'm going to
go up to shift 1 if you can't remember
one is where you get all these
statistics functions once you've
inputted the data so I'll go to one then
under this menu I want to go to 4 for
variable and hopefully this screen rings
a bell so 2 X bar that's what we've been
calling me recently that's going to give
me my mean so I'm gonna go ahead and see
equals so I'll write that down now that
I've got that so I've got a record on it
so this is part for my mean I'm gonna
write X bar that's the note a
in there equals 34.1 and then I'll clear
that out and I'll go back to shift 1 for
for variable and this time I'm going to
go to 3 um you can just make out the
Sigma there the resolution on my
calculator screen is not great but
hopefully you can read that I'll press 3
and this is going to give me standard
deviations so I get Sigma equals 14.5 I
think one decimal place should be
sufficient because I don't think they've
asked for any specifics ok great so in
fact these two numbers all I needed my
calculator for so I'll clear that out
don't need it any longer and now I just
need to use the mean and the standard
deviation and make a bit of a comparison
with the first set of rats in my
experiment it says comment on the claim
the increased motivation of the second
group of rats has improved performance
in general but decrease the consistency
so there's two claims being made here
improved performance and then decreased
consistency so where do I get that from
how can I interpret that well if you
have a look at the first set of data
they had a mean time of 46 and if you do
a just a you know straight comparison
there these guys a way fast on you know
46 seconds versus 34.1 that's a big
that's a statistically significant
reduction in time so I think we can
definitely say performance was generally
faster but then when you have a look at
the standard deviation that was handed
to us in the original data set that was
8 whereas the standard deviation here is
14.5 so it's much larger which means
that we have a much more spread out set
of data for our rats so that's what
means less consistency wider spread
equals less consistent data so I think
we can if you have a look here it says
comment on that claim I think we can say
that the data bears that out based on
our calculation of mean and standard
deviation for each of the data sets so
hopefully that all makes sense
in summary you know we're using
technology when we get two points like
like this and you kind of like look at
this integral and think you know I could
do trapezoidal rule for this but if I
access to technology there's no reason
not to use it and that's where we get
all these decimals from we will see
later on that you'll get tables of
values where these mystery decimal
values come from
that is that they've used technology to
go and evaluate them and then we can use
it in a fairly simple way